you know who I'm envious of people who
work in a job that has to do with their
college major journalists who study
journalism engineers who studied
engineering the truth is these folks are
no longer the rule but the exception a
2010 study found that only a quarter of
college graduates work in a field that
relates to their degree I graduated with
not one but two degrees in biology to my
parents dismay I am neither a doctor nor
a scientist years of studying DNA
replication and photosynthesis did
little to prepare me for a career in
technology I had to teach myself
everything from sales marketing strategy
even a little programming on my own I
had never held the title of product
manager before I sent my resume in to
Etsy I had already been turned down by
Google and several other firms and was
getting frustrated the company had
recently gone public so as part of my
job application I read the IPO filings
from cover to cover and built a website
from scratch which included my analysis
of the business and for ideas for new
features it turned out the team was
actively working on two of those ideas
and had seriously considered a third I
got the job we all know people who were
ignored or overlooked at first but went
on to prove their critics wrong my
favorite story
Brian Acton an engineering manager who
was rejected by both Twitter and
Facebook before co-founding whatsapp the
mobile messaging platform that would
sell for 19 billion dollars the hiring
systems we built in the 20th century are
failing us and causing us to miss out on
people with incredible potential the
advances in robotics machine learning
are transforming the way we work
automating routine tasks and many
occupations while augmenting and
amplifying human labour in others at
this rate we should all be expecting to
do jobs we've never done before
for the rest of our careers so what are
the tools and strategies we need to
identify tomorrow's high performers in
search for answers I've consulted with
leaders across many sectors read dozens
of reports and research papers and
conducted some of my own talent
experiments my quest is far from over
but here are three ideas to take forward
one expand your search we only look for
talent in the same place as we always do
gifted child programs Ivy League schools
prestigious organizations we're gonna
get the same results we always have
baseball was transformed when the
cash-strapped Oakland Athletics started
recruiting players who didn't score
highly of traditionally valued metrics
like runs batted in but who had the
ability to help the team score points
and win games this idea is taking hold
outside of sports the head of design and
research at Pinterest told me that
they've built one of the most diverse
and high-performing teams in Silicon
Valley because they believe that no one
type of person holds a monopoly on
talent they've worked hard to look
beyond major tech hubs and focus on
designers portfolios not their pedigrees
to hire for performance inspired by my
own job experience I co-founded a hiring
platform called head light which gives
candidates an opportunity to shine just
as teams have tryouts and plays have
auditions candidates should be asked to
demonstrate their skills before they're
hired our clients are benefiting from 85
years of employment research which shows
that work samples are one of the best
predictors of success on the job if
you're hiring a data analyst give them a
spreadsheet of historical data and ask
them for their key insights if you're
hiring a marketing manager have them
plan a launch campaign for a new product
and if you're a candidate don't wait for
an employer to ask seek out ways to
showcase your unique skills and
abilities outside of just a standard
resume and cover letter 3 get the bigger
picture I've heard about recruiters were
quick to label a candidate but job
hopper based on a single short stint on
the resume read about professors who are
more likely to ignore identical messages
from students
because their name was black or Asian
instead of white I was almost put on a
special-needs track as a child a month
into kindergarten my teacher wrote a
page-long memo noting that I was
impulsive had a short attention span and
despite my wonderful curiosity I was
exhausting to work with the principal
asked my parents into a meeting asked my
mother if there had been complications
at birth and suggested I meet with a
school psychologist my father saw what
was happening and quickly explained our
family situation as recent immigrants we
lived in the Attic of a home that cared
for adults with mental disabilities my
parents worked nights to make ends meet
and I had little opportunity to spend
time with kids my own age is it really a
surprise that an under stimulated five
year old boy might be a little excited
in a kindergarten classroom after an
entire summer by himself until we get a
holistic view of someone our judgment of
them will always be flawed
let's stop equating experience with
ability credentials with competence
let's stop settling for the safe
familiar choice and leave the door open
for someone who could be amazing
we need employers to let go of outdated
hiring practices and embrace new ways of
identifying and cultivating talent and
candidates can help by learning to tell
their story in powerful and compelling
ways we could live in a world where
people are seen for what they're truly
capable of and have the opportunity to
realize their full potential so let's go
out and build it thank you
[Applause]